[Music]
what's that from
it's my theme song my live stream song
every morning every morning when i wake
up the eyes open go guys
hello honey no relation to coffee cola
which we're talking about that just
keeps you up for how many days oh my god
for date you finally tried it coffee
cola uh i did the coca-cola coffee cola
yeah and then the coffee vanilla flavor
correlation
not a brand integration is it caffeine
no it's like coke but then it tastes
like coffee
and coke and caffeine yeah but there's
only like 10 milligrams
i think there's more caffeine than an
actual coke but i don't think they add
the
coffee into the cola it just tastes like
coffee what came first the coke or the
cola
[Laughter]
because it first tastes like coca-cola
and then it after tastes like coffee
so you get the coffee breath with the
coca-cola feeling wait so you tried it
yeah i tried the vanilla one and i tried
the coffee one it's good
oh interesting because i really liked
coca-cola vanilla love it that was
pretty good too well my issue is the
sweetness so you said it's equally as
sweet as a coca-cola but it's sweet see
i like my coffee
just black with nothing in it oh you
won't like this
you know me [ __ ] i don't chase
i don't taste either i replace what
about like
what about tea do you like a sweet tea
or i i like all my things unsweetened
typically
it's bitter like that like you know
you're like were you in asian stuff
you like decided i just i just take a
bite out of a ginseng
diabetes runs in the family not to get
like so heavy and dark
same but you ruined this video all four
grandparents have diabetes and my dad
has diabetes
why is it the worst deep
there's different levels of diabetes
these are diabetes olympics like haha
you don't need shots you know we don't
like to you know
compete in the family oh you guys rise
united uh but grandma took the cake
grandma took the cake
she ate the cake is she alive oh the
cake was too sweet you know
we lost grandma we lost for other
reasons though oh
um lung cancer okay we're getting really
deep well speaking of that let's talk
about my nicotine addiction because
we're addicted to caffeine and we're
also addicted to nicotine raise your
hand if you're addicted to nicotine
not me not anymore i think you're alone
in this me neither
um no but truly though julie though i i
the last time i was here that night i
picked up one of those puff bars
you know those like what is that like
the vape bars the vape things it's
called puff bar even though it sounds
like a rice crispy
but it's actually like the vape thing of
bobbers with like
magical flavors like soju flavors aloe
grape
lychee ice aloe green that's how they
get you they they
they [ __ ] lure you in with the asian
flavor
it's also color for kids they look like
crayons
you know what i mean like that draws me
in dangerous but i'm just like
i i'm off of it so currently i'm off of
it it's been like five days
withdrawals and you get all antsy and
pissed and [ __ ] i've been eating like
[ __ ] because i need that oral fixation
yeah but that's the thing it's like so
do we agree that we need a vice
everyone needs something yeah i
transferred to something healthy
climbing high mountains well not
everyone has the calves okay
yeah have you seen his caps he has he
does have great calves though show the
calves show the cats i used to have very
small calves
uh-huh but i got cast now thank you very
much
i expect it better did you put body
gloss on yeah dude oh my god this is so
shiny look at that gastroc
i'm greasy it looks like a honey big ham
on thanksgiving day
he hasn't showered in like five days he
has honey glaze i showered last night
joey's honey wait okay how often are we
showering these days let's be real
every day
though we shouldn't use shampoo i want
to show you because it
actually creates dandruff because it
dries your skin that's what happens to
me oh they say that
wash your hair every two days yeah wash
it once in a while
but then like that's why it gets greasy
but look how nice joe's hair is too
well it's kind of dry did you watch this
dry because i watched it last night wait
can we talk about how joe is my [ __ ]
imposter
so i did this because i thought sherry
was gonna come through with her outfit
and i was like yo i got the same exact
outfit literally
and the last time i wore this this is
literally a gel
last time i wore this people were like
joel i thought that was sherry
we get mistaken all the time i know all
this at heart
especially at they'll be like sherry
cola and i'm like sorry
today i happen to not wear that damn hat
i want to switch it up with a little
short sleeve hoodie
i wanted to surprise you a little short
sleeve hoodie this literally is the
oldest hoodie look how loose like this
looks like a vagina
it looks like a vagina did you make that
i've seen tighter
they usually come tighter to me you know
hey come on let's go listen
listen i don't personally know her i
don't personally know her but
she looks familiar but yeah i literally
wore that exact same outfit so are you
coming for me are you
stealing my identity no i wanted a
twinsies with you
right but you know it was the fan's idea
not mine well that's what they say
couples start to look alike
as you start dating you know your is
good well because when you say
hawkins style like yeah you and geo for
example because taika
looks like both of you so there's that
bridge well that's called biology
right
can we do a punnett square
but me and jio look alike but because he
looks like the both of you
seeing you two next to him it's like
whoa they kind of [ __ ] look alike i
don't agree at all i think taco is 100
of barclone
i completely disagree with his
characters definitely has geology
you know
yeah like if you look at him you don't
go well i guess jill looks a little more
asian anyways but then like
you don't go like he's mexican like i
think he's for sure asian baby but you
can tell he's mixed though
do you think geo looks more and more
asian because she hangs out with you nah
she always just look honey
she did she actually used to look more
asian
just second-hand asian you just like get
contact asian
she's so asian looking that her mexican
friend put her in a youtube skit of how
to get an asian girl
and she played the asian girl wait what
year was this
2009. this was back in the day 2025
in the future yeah that's hilarious
that's when
uh geo comes out as asian i saw that
youtube video
coming out uh video anyway everyone calm
down um
how the [ __ ] are we feeling everyone go
around and say one word that describes
their weak
awesome awesome you can't
copy my [ __ ] you know what actually just
to dim both of your lights right now
i hate the word awesome you will never
hear me say that
i love that word i don't know i it would
never come out of my mouth you know why
never that's awesome i've never been
about it doesn't mean
what it means like you you said awesome
in terms of like great
right but awesome actually means like
you're like dumbfounded
yeah you're taking a bath yeah i saw him
yesterday yes
i'm like i love where i live it's
awesome all right he just moved
he said he can't stop talking about
vegan he doesn't realize that there are
people
keep asking me questions there are
terrible moments in history that have
been described
as awesome like for example a bomb right
see what i'm saying he's not he's not
being sensitive about that at all
and also like now words like that's bomb
also mean awesome
people still say that's bob oh yeah all
right i say that all the time i say that
whenever i see
like someone no whenever i see
a a a bomb ass a bomb ass [ __ ] yeah
that's
that's different bomb ass burger but if
you be like oh i'm thirsty
that's the bomb no one knows
that's 2003 that's the
box that's like a drink commercial dude
yeah that is a soda company
if i heard that in 2003
[Laughter]
drinking water that's the bomb that's
the bomb
it's a scrapped corporate commercial
it's a strap-on commercial
i'm going to drink some water now it's a
sunny d commercial
it's so sunny it's a capri sun
commercial oh
that's the bomb dude mentos was the best
commercial
ah literally mentos was more like a tied
bleach pen
like saluted remember the one where like
okay i remember the guy
was wearing this black suit and he sits
on a bench and the bench was freshly
painted so it left like white stripes
and he was like huh he pops the mentos
and he lays all the way down
he rolls around and now he's a striped
suit i forgot that one all the
commercials were just like if life gives
you lemons type of stuff right
like gives you mentos yeah but if they
should actually have somebody do it
because it would look like [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then you're holding up the
mentos and you're like i don't think
this works
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like the
infomercial before version of the
mentos commercial take the best part is
he takes it to the dry cleaners and
she's like oh my god
do you want me to remove these lines or
and then she has to take a mentos
ripple effect they still sell
yeah and they come in like chewables now
they got fruit ones too
oh really yeah they're fruit gum they
have mentos gum now
that's [ __ ] awesome they're branching
out
today's video is brought to you by
upstart upstart is an easy way to pay
off your debt
with a personal loan all online
or if you're looking for a way to fund
your projects because
the way your money is moving and the
cash flow isn't in your favor
that's what i did so i was building my
home gym at home
and you know some like my home gym is
for like all my barbell stuff
and i was expecting a payment to come in
for bartle brigade but because the
timing of it is off and then you know
when you're moving there's all kinds of
unforeseen costs like interior design
landscaping all that i'm like oh shoot
i don't want to have to wait another
month where i
am gymless i don't have a place to train
because i want to be able to train
at home especially once grandma goes
back home it's just going to be mediocre
so i use upstart and i was able to buy
the gym so i can have it
come in in time without having to wait
for an extra month or two
for the bottle brigade payment that
helped out so that's pretty cool and
what's awesome about upstart is like
it basically takes five minutes to check
and you get up to like 50 000
that's a lot of money yeah so it helps
out you know like you're trying to lower
your
monthly payments on your credit or if
you're just trying to figure out other
cash
options to help fund whatever projects
you need so please go to upstart.com
off the record if it seems like this is
something that can help you
it only takes five minutes to check like
joe says and the loan amount will be
determined by your credit score your
income and
the other information that you put in on
your application so make sure you go to
upstart.com
off the record i love reese's peanut
butter cups
and they have reese's peanut butter
unsweetened though
where is the unsweet candy
i just want the chew without the sugar i
want the sugar on the side i want the
option
the option of a sweet you're at the
wonka factory and you're like let's
reign it in yeah yeah that's okay it's
like willy
willy like what's your blood sugar level
because this is
[ __ ] that movie was a trip a chocolate
river a little too much i
watched it recently i need to re-watch
it how's the new one did we watch the
remake i haven't watched any of them
the johnny depp one doesn't even compare
to the og ones
the best one and because all the
technology that weird elevator that just
goes flying and you can like see the
string
that's what movie making is all about do
you need to be in like the child mindset
to watch it or
not [ __ ] no dude so i can watch it i can
watch it
now with seeing all the cg that i've
seen and i can watch it and i'll still
be wowed by it
yeah i think you'll appreciate it
certain movies i don't know about it
especially because you want to get
bulldozers and play ping-pong together
with
bulldozers it's an idea if you like
[ __ ] like that you'll watch this and go
oh [ __ ] this guy
he's living the dream he'll probably
watch him be like i could probably do
this
just you have your own chocolate factory
exactly you know what i mean just do
taika a favor and fast forward it
from all the grandpa bed stuff
it's a whole hour of that before it's a
grandparents swinger set they're
sleeping like this they're literally
69 69 grandparents they are so poor
they're doing the z or what is this yeah
these are perfect right angles can we
talk about that what the [ __ ] 90
degree is happening right now
you could really yo that is an instagram
post look at this square
look at this [ __ ] square very
straightforward wait i have a question
if y'all could have
a factory of your own what would be the
item the special
oh what would we manufacture bitcoin
bitcoin factory but something graspable
babe
graspable all right damn get back to me
what would you do you go first yeah you
go you came up with you can't be asking
us questions and then i have answers
she's going to use our answers to give
her time for anthony yeah it's
the best one somehow i just emotionally
manipulate all of you
puppet strings
is it is it hats is it sparkling water
is there a reason to lure in the the
town
are you trying to make money why are you
trying to you okay okay
am i making stuff here or am i just an
expert you're pied pipering people
yeah what am i actually doing here
that's providing jobs for the town like
what do you what do you
do is it for you or is it for them
that's the question that's deep
yeah you got to set a goal i want a
factory for me
what do you mean i first wanted to say a
[ __ ] factory
i don't want to make my passion my work
right right right
right you are what you do and then you
get tired of it and i don't even want to
know what happens next
because then you want to bring work home
no no i don't want to stop me
like i'm tired of touching [ __ ] all day
like i don't know why i look at it
let's talk about we have 45 seconds to
talk about [ __ ]
we got way more than that if [ __ ] was
an acronym
what would it stand for pure
usable usable
underrated underrated sexy saucy
saucy yeah
sexy saucy yeah i don't think it should
be saucy i don't know i think you should
be soft pussy's on heroin
sexy see bart's face bart's face is why
it shouldn't be sausage no we're also
almost thinking like
doesn't make sense the y has got to be
some sort of object we have like
four adjectives into nothing
it goes nowhere very simple that's how
bart makes simple things fun
we're making the merch we're going to
make the merch simple
is that the s word no no soft sexy and
soft it's complicated
yes sherry sherry pure
underrated sexy sherry
yours yes
yummy yeah yeah yummy dude
there it is that's that's wonderful make
the merch make the merge
yeah so i saw you do a stand up on the
beach how was that was this 20 minutes i
thought it was 15 minutes
but you see me trying to like wrap it up
how was that dude is that weird quick
game was spin the bottle
and do you and like the audience
walk on the beach together to yes so
everyone has shoes in their sand and
sand in their shoes that's that's also
very deep
because the sand in the shoe or is the
shoe in the sand
bruh it came first what came first
it's just an infinite infinite cycle so
yes i've been doing stand up stand up is
back they're getting very creative
parking lot of a barber shop we're
talking on the beach my next show
is on the moon
uh will rogers this is a random beast so
basically there's a microphone there's
lights
there's speakers and um people are just
picnic style
in the sand it's very cute it's very
windy my hair was like i mean
you know memoirs of a geisha so when
you're in the green room are you just
standing right there the rainbow coming
onto the stage
and you just walk from this i see sherry
walk over
under the pier i see you're walking i'm
buried
and only my head is above the sand
i'm underwater the green room is
underwater no there's no green room
so you're just part of the audience yeah
we're just well we're behind the
audience
i see because you know me i like to make
an entrance honey yeah i was like an
entrepreneur
that would have been i don't know how to
serve we'll ride a turtle or something
do you know any [ __ ] turtles that are
available
turtles are very busy in the pandemics
yeah well you don't know how to swim
i can get from a to b how far is a and b
a pool oh okay i can get from the the
the top and the bottom of the pool
but i'm not like i i can't tread in a
river for a long time like this is
[ __ ]
really big
there's like [ __ ] white water rapids
this is [ __ ] just trending
going against the currents it's
but people are like really good swimmers
i can get by i remember when i i used to
take swim lessons
i remember i would go back to shanghai
and one of the activities i did one
summer was just swim lessons
and i remember we literally we were
[ __ ] swimming
back and forth from the short side of
the pool not even the long side
and i remember like i couldn't hold my
breath long enough so i started drinking
the water
that's actually a tactic wait that'll
keep you alive for longer for a little
bit
have we talked about this why did you
drink the water not in the ocean
that sounds like drowning no drowning is
if the water is going through your nose
if you start drinking the water you can
survive longer under are you talking
true because it uh no oxygen in the
water
you slowly start to gillify it exactly
there's oxygen in the water you're
acclimated so for example if you were to
plug my nose right now
and i can't breathe through my nose but
i'm drinking water i'm technically still
surviving yeah no way
my nose that's why waterboarding when
they put the thing over your mouth you
can't drink the water
they're not drinking it they're not
drinking chocolate on water
torture
do you feel better now are you glad i
feel like
michael i feel like michael [ __ ]
films right now oh that didn't work at
all that [ __ ] you should start a youtube
channel where it's like survival lessons
with sherry
oh it's pretty good you're debunking all
these uh survival with sherry yeah
short clips
you want to know how to survive a
burning building go in the freezer first
here we go guys throw water oh [ __ ] go
inside
i really thought something magical was
going to happen right we're so we're all
scientists today yeah we're all
scientists we're just trying we're just
trying stuff it gave me that idea to
drink water while you're swimming
i just did it it wasn't gross i was
underwater i mean well
chlorine i actually love the smell of
polar oh god
water right [ __ ] these people no she's
drinking it though that's weird
[ __ ] you drinking it is weird
hey dogs do it all the time listen
chlorine is a hell of a drug nicotine
sure
chlorine talk about underrated
hits once it hits once once you peek
how does it feel it takes a while to
kick in but
i also love the gas station you don't
give a [ __ ] i don't give a
but i'm more of a nail polish [ __ ] oh
the remover
babe remover or the polish honey yeah
dude i'll smell that sponge all day long
pick one though
i will legit stand outside of a nail
salon
let me smell your towels real quick let
me get a whiff
pretending you're looking at something
on your phone so you like just like the
alcoholy like chemical smell
i guess it sounds kind of sharpies
sharpie i'm i'm a middle this is like
goldilocks okay this is like goldilocks
nail polish is just right yeah sharpie i
don't hate it paint thinner drier
erasers
stronger paint thinner dry erase markers
thicker
oh what's that you don't know he's got
no you don't spend time at home
he don't know [ __ ] this guy don't know
[ __ ] bro god you were paying a house
before [ __ ]
this guy he knows what the adjective is
though awesome
fun scholar over here awesome
grow up
[Music]
you